präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die korona pandemie beschäftigt uns nun
bald ein jahr
wir haben viel gelernt eine anfängliche
hoffnung hat sich nicht bestätigt dass
es nämlich eine harmlose erkrankung sein
im gegenteil ist profit 19 nicht nur
aber insbesondere für menschen mit einer
vorerkrankung oder höheren lebensalter
eine ernst zu nehmende oder auch
tödliche gefahr
die reduzierung von kontakten frau
bundeskanzlerin ist deshalb notwendig es
ist notwendig abstand zu halten maske zu
tragen auf die hygiene zu achten
die waren app zu nutzen zu lüften wo
immer das möglich ist
gerade vor weihnachten als dem
familienfest sind wir alle in besonderer
weise gefordert auch rücksicht zu nehmen
auf unseren älteren familienangehörigen
wir müssen weiter gemeinsam auf
verantwortungsgefühl auch vernunft und
auch vorsicht setzen der umgang mit
corona ist auch ausdruck der sittlichen
reife eines jeden einzelnen
das letzte mal haben wir eine debatte
kurz nach einer bund länder runde
geführt
nun führen wir eine debatte vermutlich
kurz davor die ursprünglich für den
november geplanten
freiheitseinschränkung wurden
zwischenzeitlich schon bis in den januar
ausgedehnten länder haben die für den
dezember beschlossenen maßnahmen
inzwischen zum teil verbindlich
verschärft und die frau bundeskanzlerin
hat sich hier heute die empfehlungen der
leopoldina zu eigen gemacht einen
tiefgreifenden und länger andauernden
lockdown in unserem land zu beschließen
unabhängig von der bewertung dazu später
im einzelnen zeigt sich die halbwertzeit
der ankündigungen erklärungen und
verhaltensregeln wird immer kürzer und
damit wird auch die wichtigste ressource
in dieser krise immer knapper
nämlich die berechenbarkeit staatlichen
handelns im herbst und winter kam
offenbar so überrascht dass er nun
wieder genau dort sind wo wir im
frühjahr schon einmal war
man kann man darf einer regierung nicht
zum vorwurf machen dass wir in einer
pandemie leben das kann und darf man ihr
nicht zum vorwurf machen aber man muss
kritisieren dass der sommer und viele
monate und die möglichkeiten des
gesamtstaats nicht genutzt wurden um
genau diese situation für die wir jetzt
stehen abzuwenden
ja in der tat brinkhaus wir haben
bereits im frühjahr dringend dazu
aufgerufen flächendeckend die versorgung
von fft zwei masken sicherzustellen
wir haben schon im frühjahr angeregt
auch die kapazitäten der veterinär und
zahnmedizin zu nutzen um die test
kapazitäten auszuweiten
insofern sollten sie nicht den eindruck
erwecken es habe nicht auch hinweise und
unterstützende stimmen gegeben
der bayerische ministerpräsident hat ja
sogar schon mit großer geste neue
maßnahmen beschlossen
der kollege mützenich hat das auftreten
als theatralisch bezeichnet das möge
jeder für sich beurteilen
aber welche wirkung soll beispielsweise
eine ausgangssperre von 21 uhr bis 5 uhr
morgens haben vom gassigehen mit dem
hund um den block geht jedenfalls keine
infektionsgefahr mit aus das sind liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bei aller
notwendigkeit der kontakt beschränkung
und der pandemie bekämpfung
das sind rein symbolische
einschränkungen die erstens unwirksam
sind zweitens unverhältnismäßig in die
freiheit der menschen eingreifen und die
drittens dem publikum nur ein planvolles
vorgehen simulieren sollen das braucht
niemand
vom bundesgesundheitsminister hat
neulich an zitat karriere gemacht
man würde mit dem wissen von heute das
kann ich ihnen sagen kein einzelhandel
mehr schließen das wird nicht noch mal
passieren
das sagte jens spahn anfang september im
rückblick auf das frühjahr wie ist davon
die aktuelle fassung weniger wochen
danach mit dem wissen von heute würde
man gestern nicht mehr gesagt haben dass
die entscheidung vorgestern nötig war
niemand wirft der regierung vor
entscheidungen unter unsicherheit zu
treffen und sich zu korrigieren
nein das mache ich nicht nein ich werfe
etwas anderes vor
die fortwährende korrektur der korrektur
wirft fragen nach der wissenschaftlichen
evidenz aller maßnahmen auf nach wenigen
wochen
dabei hat jens spahn ja recht
unverändert wird er belegte pauschale
gefahren die von der kultur und von
museen von der speisegastronomie unter
hygiene-regeln kosmetikstudios oder
schulen ausgehen soll
und nun geht es an den handel für den
dasselbe gilt unverändert eine dauer
durch haltbare strategie die auf
wissenschaftlich begründete maßnahmen
setzt kein zweifel
regional bei hohen infektionsgeschehen
sind weitere reduzierungen der kontakte
nötig so hatten wir den beschluss der
bund länder hunde indessen auch
verstanden zitat weil besonders extremen
infektions lagen mit einer instanz von
über 200 neue infektionen und die fusion
infektionsgeschehen sollen die
umfassenden allgemeinen maßnahmen
nochmals erweitert werden um kurzfristig
eine deutliche absenkung des
infektionsgeschehen zu erreichen
damit liegt eine regelung für ein
regional differenziertes handeln gegen
steigendes infektionsgeschehen doch auf
dem tisch warum setzen sie nicht einfach
das um was sie bereits in der bund
länder runde beschlossen hatten aus
unserer sicht sind nicht pauschale und
flächendeckende maßnahmen nötig sondern
regionales und vor allem berechenbares
handeln wir hatten mit unserem vorschlag
zum paragrafen 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes vorschläge
gemacht wie wir bevölkerung und behörden
mit einer klaren wenn dann zur ordnung
handlungssicherheit geben könnten
genau diese berechenbarkeit fehlt nun
liebend gern würden wir darauf
verzichten binnen nur drei wochen die
praktische bestätigung für unsere
befürchtung erhalten zu haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen er war
gewiss amüsant gemeint der werbespot der
bundesregierung zu besonderen helden der
pandemie in diesem haus denken bei
carola helden die allermeisten wenn ich
ihr halle vermutlich zuerst an die
beschäftigten in heilberufen an
diejenigen die in unserem land in alltag
aufrecht erhalten wir denken bei corona
helden auch an diejenigen die sich trotz
der gefährdung der eigenen
wirtschaftlichen existenz den mut nicht
nehmen lassen das sind die helden im
sport bestand das heldentum des
studenten darin faul wie ein waschbär
auf der couch zu sein
viele studierende bemühen sich mühsam um
kontakt zu dozenten und vermissen
digitale lernangebote schmerzlich wer
den verlust von lebenszeit fürchten muss
der wird über die einladung zum gammeln
auf der couch nicht unbefangen lachen
können aber darum geht es nicht
was geschenkt aber und das ist eben
nochmals zum ausdruck gekommen
dieser clip bringt die krisenstrategie
der bundesregierung auf den punkt der
stillstand als die nationale
kraftanstrengung und nun frau
bundeskanzlerin steht uns ja ein
weiteres kapitel bevor wie sie hier eben
dargelegt haben manche haben schon vor
dem ratschlag der leopoldina mit
frankreich argumentiert
dort gab es ja einen mehrwöchigen karten
lockdown um die fallzahlen zu reduzieren
jetzt wird bei uns der eindruck erweckt
einmal bis zum 10
januar schließen um danach wieder eine
form der normalität zu erreichen
daran habe ich zweifel in der tat in der
tat daran habe ich zweifel denn
ausgerechnet gestern kamen die aktuellen
zahlen aus franken
und leider steigt dort die zahl der
neuen infektionen wieder das wird man
beobachten müssen
damit ist doch klar ohne einen dazu
gleich ohne ohne an umfassenden einsatz
des impfstoffs der noch lange auf sich
warten lassen wird gibt es keine
garantie dass aus kurzer herzen
nachhaltiger erfolg wird im gegenteil es
ist unsicher ob nicht die kurze härte zu
einer langen herr zu werden muss und
danach ist dann nur eines sicher nämlich
der hohe soziale und wirtschaftliche
schaden des stillstands für das landes
und deshalb sollten wir miteinander
sollten wir miteinander vor einer bund
länder runde sprechen ob es strategische
alternativen gibt ja distanz im alltag
aber wir bleiben dabei angesichts der
zahl der toten und wer betroffen ist
angesichts der zahl der hospitalisierung
und wer hospitalisiert ist angesichts
des besonderen risikos dass ältere
menschen mit menschen mit
vorerkrankungen tragen der kernpunkt der
krisenbewältigung wenn sie dauerhaft
durch haltbar sein soll muss der schutz
der besonderen risikogruppen seien die
gehören in das zentrum staatlichen
handelns jetzt ist hier gesagt worden
oft genug vorgetragen worden ja dabei
handelte sich nach der zahl des
gemeinsamen bundesausschusses um 27 35
millionen menschen
die könne man ja gar nicht alle schützen
dabei weist die regierung selber besser
als frau bundeskanzlerin mit mit ihre
ihrer rechtsverordnung zum impfen mit
ihrem impfplan haben sie ja bereits eine
klassierung nach unterschiedlichen
risikoprofil vorgelegen
da sind zum einen die menschen mit
vorerkrankungen
und die hochbetagten und haben ein
anderes risiko profil als noch sport
tiefe mittsechziger dass er nehme ich
ihre it strategie und aus diesem grund
kann und muss sich der schutz von
arabischer gruppen auch praktisch
bewähren
indem wir dafür sorgen dass zum beispiel
in altenpflegeheimen die von herrn
brinkhaus in der letzten debatte
angesprochenen defizite beseitigt werden
und in dem wir menschen im alltag in dem
wir menschen im alltag frau
bundeskanzlerin nicht zumuten jetzt
gegenwärtig draußen im kalten vor den
rande zu stehen
in einer schlange möglicherweise 8 und
noch nicht mal jeder auf den abstand um
danach nahezu allein einkaufen zu gehen
nachdem man zuvor auch eng gesetzt in
busch angereist ist da haben wir einmal
dort bessere möglichkeiten um den
menschen zu helfen
aktuell setzen wir jeden monat und 20
milliarden euro ein um die
einnahmeverluste für die pauschalen
schließungen zu kompensieren was hätten
die mit dem geld alles tun können wir
hatten taxigutscheine finanzieren können
schulen und altenheime mit luftfiltern
ausstatten können test kapazitäten
ausweiten können und da ist der
unterschied
sie setzten milliarden ein um die
schäden des stillstands zu dämpfen wir
wollen mittel einsetzen um öffentliches
leben zu erhalten
dort wo es möglich ist wären übrigen
auch für den steuerzahler langfristig
der bessere weg
wir haben konkrete konkrete maßnahmen
beantragt ganz konkrete den
haushaltsberatungen das rkw hat 68
zusätzliche stellen für die
informationstechnik beantragt war ein
großes problem der nachverfolgung von
infektionsketten ist doch das noch mit
wachs und unzureichend
gearbeitet wird was hat die große
koalition gemacht trotz milliarden
mehrausgaben von den 68 des rk ii vom
rkw beantragten stellen hat cdu csu spd
gerade mal vier stellen genehmigt und
das ist eine krass falsche
schwerpunktsetzung da es an der falschen
stelle von gegen gespart worden
wir haben konkret beantragt eine
milliarde euro zur versorgung der wunde
rebellengruppen mit ffp zwei masken
bereit zu stellen nachdem sie frau
bundeskanzlerin der letzten debatte
gesagt haben die normalen alltags masten
burtons und dass wir beim einkauf keinen
hinreichenden schutz
das haben wir ernst genommen und wir
haben daraus die konsequenz gezogen dass
wir die staatlichen mittel dort
einsetzen müssen damit den menschen mit
höheren schutzniveau ein alltagsleben
ermöglicht wird die folgen dieser
strategie meine damen und herren sind am
haushalts ablesbar 180 milliarden euro
neue schulden und die wirklichen folgen
für den arbeitsmarkt und die deutsche
wirtschaft werden wir erst langfristig
nächsten und in den nächsten jahren
sehen wir würden milde urteilen über die
schulden frau bundeskanzlerin wenn die
hilfsprogramme wenigstens ankämen es
wurden aber großzügige hilfen in
aussicht gestellt
ich sage weiter damit wurde auch ein
gewisses stillhalten von ländern und
branchen erreicht doch was ist daraus
geworden
von den elf von den hilfen ist nichts
ausgezahlt worden
wir wollen keine hilfen kürzen
schneider wir wollen dass die hilfe
tatsächlich ankommen und deshalb ist
unser konkreter vorschlag erstens folgen
sie dem rat der länder
wirtschaftsministerin und
wirtschaftsminister erhöhen sie die
abschlagszahlungen auf 500.000 euro und
fassen wie november und dezember hilfe
in einer hilfe zusammen die
unbürokratisch ausgezahlt werden kann
damit aus der infektionswelle nicht eine
pleitewelle wird der finanzminister
könnte und sollte sich öffnen wenn auch
der wirtschaftsminister sich inzwischen
aus spricht dafür den steuerlichen
verlust rück tagaus zu drehen schulz ich
weiß nicht warum sich ihr haus dagegen
sperrt ist ein reiner liquiditätseffekt
für den staaten ob die verluste dieses
jahres in der zukunft genutzt werden
oder ob die verluste dieses jahres gegen
die vergangenen steuerschuld angerechnet
wird das ist für den staat von einer
liquidität ein unterschied aber nicht
vom steueraufkommen insgesamt es gibt
noch einen einzigen unterschied
zukünftig steuern zahlen können nur
betriebe die es dann überhaupt noch gibt
deshalb sollten sie einen beitrag dazu
leisten dass diese betriebe über diese
schwierige zeit kommt das dilemma ihrer
krisenpolitik ist dass das schließen und
kompensieren dass einnahmeausfall
irgendwann selbst in der viertgrößten
volkswirtschaft der welt an grenzen
stößt in bemerkenswerter offenheit hat
dass der kollege brink austen der
vergangenen sitzungswoche der vergangen
debatte ja auch gesagt er hat gesagt ab
dem nächsten jahr könnten sich die
länder nicht mehr darauf verlassen dass
der bund das aus dem bundeshaushalt
allein die hilfen geleistet werden er
bringt aus
da haben sie in der tat die grenzen
dessen was fiskalisch mögliches
angesprochen nur ob es aus dem bundes
oder aus dem landeshaushalt aus den
länderhaushalten geleistet wird ist am
ende einer leihe denn für die
steuerzahlerinnen und
halo ist es die gleiche steuerlast die
sie tragen müssen die steuerzahlerinnen
und steuerzahler stehen nämlich dem
gesamtstaat gegenüber und nicht länder
oder dem bundeshaushalt
wenn sie also diese grenzen der
fiskalischen leistungsfähigkeit zu recht
unseres staates betonen dann müssen sie
auch die notwendigen konsequenzen daraus
ziehen 180 milliarden euro
neuverschuldung die höchste
neuverschuldung die zahl ist noch
unvollkommen denn hinzu kommen ja noch
unsere haftungsverpflichtungen für
beispielsweise new generation das 750
milliarden programm der europäischen
union
und nun vor diesem enormen hintergrund
angesichts dieser enormen dimensionen
sagt der bundesfinanzminister die grenze
der neuverschuldung ist noch nicht
erreicht oder die grenze der
verschuldung ist nicht erreicht für mich
ist das keine entwarnung sondern ganz im
gegenteil das klingt geradezu für für
mich wie die rechtfertigung zusätzlicher
schulden herr scholz die grenze der
verschuldung darf in deutschland niemals
überhaupt in sicht geraten
das heißt nicht nur etwas nämlich für
unsere eigenen schuldentragfähigkeit wir
wirtschaften jedoch nicht alleine nur
für uns sondern die bonität und die
fiskalische stabilität der
bundesrepublik deutschland hat doch eine
enorme bedeutung für die wirtschafts und
währungsunion insgesamt
wo steht denn die wirtschafts und
währungsunion in europa ohne krippe us
bonität deutschlands
wir haben eine fiskalische
vorbildfunktion für andere in europa und
deshalb müssen wir weiter der
stabilitätsanker der europäischen union
der wirtschafts und währungsunion
bleiben
deshalb dürfen wir nicht mehr schulden
machen als überhaupt nur notwendig schon
jetzt wird in italien darüber gesprochen
zu einem schuldenerlass zu kommen unsere
französischen partner und freunde
sprechen offen darüber wie in
deutschland übrigens die grünen das
waren doch nach der
mona pandemie nicht mehr zurückkam zu
den stabilitätsregeln des vertrages von
maastricht deshalb geht es nicht nur um
die aktuellen hilfen jetzt nicht nur um
die deutsche schuldentragfähigkeit nicht
nur um fairness gegenüber unseren
steuerzahlenden nicht nur um fairness
gegenüber der nächsten generation es
geht um die integrität und
zukunftsfähigkeit der europäischen
wirtschafts und währungsunion insgesamt
die korona krise darf nicht der
ausgangspunkt der nächsten euro
schuldenkrise werden
und aus diesem wohnt und aus diesem
grund gebe kolleginnen und kollegen hat
unsere fraktion konkret über 527
änderungsanträge zum entwurf des
bundeshaushaltes 2021 dargelegt dass es
möglich ist die schuldenaufnahme zu
halbieren und zwar ohne würde und
zaubertricks 20 milliarden alleine sind
die ausgaben reste des jahres 2020 gut
50 milliarden euro ist die asyl rücklage
die wir natürlich zur reduzierung der
neuverschuldung in diesem jahr auflösen
wollen sie wollen sie bis ins jahr 2022
mittragen als rücklage ja da war man
doch um was es geht das nach der
nächsten bundestagswahl noch
milliardensummen als wahlkampf konto zur
verfügung stehen notkredite wie es sich
jetzt aufnehmen dürfen aber nur
aufgenommen werden wenn danach alle
rücklagen im haushalt aufgelöst sind das
ist auch ein gebot der haushaltswahrheit
und klarheit
das sagen nicht nur hier das sagen nicht
nur wir sondern das schreiben ihnen ja
auch führende verfassungsrechtler
gestern noch einen bemerkenswerten
interview in der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung ins stammbuch
also eine halbierung der schulden ist
möglich und dann wird es darum gehen die
gelingt die dauerhafte sanierung der
öffentlichen finanzen nach der pandemie
der bundesfinanzminister hat völlig zu
recht gesagt wir müssen aus unseren
schulden herauswachsen also eine
wachstumsorientierte politik machen bei
zugleich wieder neuer finanzieller
solidität
das war eine strategie wie sie nach 2010
unter der ägide des
bundesfinanzministers wolfgang schäuble
erfolgreich umgesetzt worden ist aber
unter ganz anderen voraussetzungen
damals haben wir haushalte sanieren
können weil aufgrund der euro krise die
zinsen nach unten gegangen sind wir
haben die zinsgewinne nutzen können das
steht nicht mehr zur verfügung die
zinsen werden sehen können sondern
risiken bestehen dass sie vielleicht
dereinst steigen könnten wir hatten die
breiten schultern der baby boomer mit
ihrer gesamten finanziellen feuerkraft
ein jahrzehnt zur verfügung die wechseln
jetzt aber auf die seite der beziehung
von ruhestands einkommen die gehen in
den ruhestand
wir hatten noch die reformen dividende
der agenda 2010 die ist reichlich
genutzt und verbraucht worden steht
jetzt aber nicht mehr zur verfügung
und deshalb wird in diesem haus mit dem
nächsten haushalt 2022 uns alle
gemeinsam und jeder hat seine meinung
dazu
ein vollkommen neuer aushandlungsprozess
bevorstehen wie wir neue öffentliche
finanzen aufstellen wie wir neu die
investitions bedürfnisse von staat und
privat ausbalancieren und inzwischen
sehen wir ja auch schon in welche
richtung das geht die sozialdemokratie
und der finanzminister sprechen über
eine vermögenssteuer die sie einführen
wollen ja aber stellen sie sicher dass
es überhaupt noch vermögen gibt die man
besteuern kann
legen sie leben aber wissen sie ich bin
ich bin da total entspannt ich würde nur
gerne einmal an praktischen vorschlag
für eine vermögenssteuer sehen wer nicht
einen bürokratischen tsunami ausgelöst
der mehr kosten verursacht als einnahmen
erzielt werden
danach können wir mal von konkreten
vorschlag sprechen gibt's nicht bündnis
90 die grünen sagen sie wollen die
steuern erhöhen
unter anderem vielleicht auch um die
neue light idee des bedingungslosen
grundeinkommens zu finanzieren für die
sie sich jetzt ausgesprochen haben
gestern sagte ein haushaltspolitiker der
grünen jahr nach der krise dürfe man
doch um gottes willen nicht zurückkehren
zur politik der schwarzen null wegen der
investitionen
ich bin auch für investitionen ich
glaube auch dass wir in den öffentlichen
haushalten ein schwerpunkt im investiven
bereich setzen müssen nachdem wir fast
ein jahrzehnt konsumtive ausgaben
gesehen haben insbesondere im bereich
der rentenpolitik die nun wie eine
hypothek im nächsten jahrzehnt die
öffentlichen haushalte belasten werden
nur dennoch dennoch gibt es einen
bewertungsunterschied sie setzen bei
investitionen das ist ihre dna und das
sei ihnen zugestanden sie setzen auf den
bereich der öffentlichen investitionen
inklusive der investitions lenkung durch
den start der planung der transformation
am wortwörtlichen grünen tisch das kann
man auch so wollen wir setzen aber auf
ein anderes konzept wir setzen auf die
soziale marktwirtschaft in der der staat
gute rahmenbedingungen schafft das
private investition in zukunft schaffen
dann haben wir im übrigen auch die
möglichkeit dann haben
wegen auch die möglichkeit öffentliche
verschuldung entbehrlich zu machen
falls deutschland endlich wieder
attraktiv werden könnte für ausländische
direktinvestitionen gehen unser land
fließen davon haben wir gegenwärtig zu
wenig immerhin die cdu sagt sie schließt
steuererhöhungen aus wir erinnern uns
allerdings auch an das jahr 2005 als
nach dem ausschluss von steuererhöhungen
danach die mehrwertsteuer erhöht worden
war sie werden sehen wir werden sehen in
welche richtung es geht für uns ist klar
wir werden nicht wir werden nichts
die wirtschaftliche erholung erreichen
indem wir den bürgerinnen und bürgern
und betrieben zusätzliche belastungen in
aussicht stellen da kann jeder für
werben
wer das will möge in diesem land für
diese position werben unseres auch noch
andere
unsere position ist dass die bürgerinnen
und bürger vertrauen verdient haben das
haben sie während der pandemie gezeigt
unsere position ist dass erfindergeist
aller biontech zukunft schafft und
deshalb braucht unser land eine
offensive für die entfesselung genau
dieser kreativität und wirtschaftlichen
dynamik durch weniger bürokratie durch
die senkung von steuern und abgaben
durch eine initiative für
forschungsfreiheit und für weltweiten
handel vielleicht ist ein jahrzehnt
politik ohne geld auch die möglichkeit
der rückbesinnung auf die freiheitliche
wirtschaftsordnung
der fdp partei und fraktionschef
christian lindner am anfang hat er
kritisiert dass die halbwertzeit der
ankündigung der bundesregierung zu kurz
sein es gibt keine berechenbarkeit für
die bevölkerung und gegen ende hat er
nochmal dargestellt dass die schulden
von heute die schulden für die kinder
sein werden und dass hier
unverantwortlich gearbeitet wird